an incredible thing happened yesterday
which is that the david pakman show
youtube channel reached an extraordinary
milestone 800,000 subscribers that's an
8 followed by 5 zeroes we have the video
it happened live on last night's Iowa
caucus stream let's take a look at the
big moment buckle in folks we are very
very close here we have reached 800
thousand subscribers amazing and I don't
know why but this has not updated how
lame is that it seems to be broken
it's stuck at $7.99 can you imagine oh
there it is amazing incredible I hope
someone records that please clip that
please send it to me I want to post that
to my Instagram page or whatever please
email me that we did it yes you can see
a riveting and very very exciting moment
but in all seriousness thank you thank
you to the 800 now getting close to 800
and 1000 of you check out a graph of our
subscribers that I put together today I
have some interesting little factoids
for you we've been building the YouTube
channel for a long time I went back and
looked our first month on YouTube we had
four subscribers I don't mean that we
gained four subscribers a day after our
entire first month on YouTube we had
four subscribers our entire second year
on YouTube we gained thirty-two hundred
subscribers an entire year 3,200
subscribers just during yesterday's
livestream of the Iowa caucuses we
gained about 600 subscribers in a three
hour stream and we reached this amazing
milestone of eight hundred thousand so
thank you so much the next goal of
course is a million will probably do
something little for nine hundred
thousand but one million is really that
nice round number now this is funny
weeks ago I started looking at the
numbers we were in Jan you know first
week of January second week of January I
was looking at the numbers I was looking
at the calendar and I was thinking we
might be able to do 800,000 by my
birthday which was on Sunday February
2nd and as we were getting closer we
were 10 days away we were five days away
and still February 2nd seemed viable and
we missed it but my calculation was only
off by like 22 hours the new goal is 1
million by Election Day ok 1 million by
November 3rd 2020 it is very hard to
predict with much precision because so
many factors can affect this right now
on socialblade which tracks this data it
looks like we're on track to hit a
million subscribers sometime between
October 12 and December so we might
clear a million three weeks before the
election we might miss it by six weeks
it could end up getting pushed into 2021
depending on what happens now as we
close in I will fine-tune the numbers
but the goal which would be so huge for
the progressive movement to have another
show enter this category in the millions
along with TYT The Young Turks it would
be huge to do it before the 2020
election I'll keep you posted but as of
right now it's possible it's possible
and thank you to the more than 800,000
of you that are currently subscribed to
our YouTube channel really feels great
to have accomplished this